le succès du jardinage peut se résumer
en un seul chiffre ce marché représente
environ 30 milliards de francs dépensés
chaque année les jardins de ville
connaissent une véritable explosion
c'est l'objet du reportage que voici les
signes et benoît mousse et pascal pedio
cultivons notre jardin
deux siècles après voltaire sept sages
leçon de vie est devenu le credo de très
nombreux citadins
désormais il existe pour tous ces
amoureux de la chlorophylle des cours de
jardinage pour se décomplexer avant de
progresser voilà c'est parler mais c'est
pas la mer qui compte ce sont les idées
vert pour 35 france et néophytes passe
deux heures avec un jardinier
professionnel à chaque session un
nouveau thème aujourd'hui les bulbes de
printemps à moi c'est de l'anti l'aider
des choses simples de manière à ce que
les gens justement plus les pratiquer et
puis de leur côté également de deux
repas seul témoin à quelqu'un d'autre et
tous vendus se rejoignent un petit peu
au niveau du jardinage et voici le
résultat chez l'une de ses anciennes
élèves un petit balcon de quelques
mètres carrés en plein coeur de paris
entouré de verdure
il est devenu la passion et la fierté de
son auteur si on a des plantes c'est
bien seulement du temps et on peut pas
se permettre de passer passionné par ce
que inévitablement l e santé elle crève
alors c'est vrai que ça demande du temps
et en plus financièrement surtout au
début c'est un investissement par
rapport au pos la poterie coûte cher
surtout pour résister au gel à paris et
y viennent fréquemment l'hiver et pour
qu'elle soit de bonne qualité il faut
mettre le prix elle a dépensé dix mille
francs pour son jardin
une goutte d'eau dans un marché qui
représente un chiffre d'affaires de plus
de 30 milliards de francs par an pas
très étonnant au vu le nombre de jardins
entretenir 14 millions et les quelque 74
millions de terrasses balcons ou bord de
fenêtre à décorer
et en ville je vois vraiment des gens
qui viennent chercher de plantes parce
qu'ils ont vraiment 20 centimètres
carrés en extérieur en plus ils auront
ils vont accrocher ça mais il arrive et
ses romans système d dans ces cas là
vous vous raccrochez ils viennent
chercher l'équipe ne pas fumer les
petites banques pour la cuisine des
plantes condimentaires des plantes
parfumées
un succès qui s'explique d'abord par un
besoin le jardinage en ville surtout
serait un dérivatif au stress à la
pollution et à londres
autant de bonnes raisons pour cultiver
sa passion comme disait la baie de l'île
au xviiie siècle la sagesse autrefois
habitait le jardin alors je crois qu'on
y trouve le repos la pro ici et la
beauté et tout est peut-être un petit
peu plus de pureté camion
extraordinaires selon les professionnels
du jardinage le phénomène devrait encore
s'amplifier
les concentrations urbaines les miasmes
de la ville ne peuvent que pousser des
français dans leur jardin match monsieur
m